hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this
is ai simplified where we learn to make
your data
useful in the previous episode we
learned how to create data sets in
vertex ai
and trained machine learning model using
automl
in this video we help our friends at
fuel symbol
build custom machine learning models
their team of machine learning experts
have decided to write their own training
code to predict the fuel efficiency of
a vehicle join me as i walk them through
the different ways in which you can run
custom training in vertex at and finally
we will kick off our training job in the
console and see how it's done
now what do we need to create a custom
job
before we submit any of the custom jobs
to vertex ci
we need to create a python training
application or custom container
to write the training code and the
dependencies
there are pre-built containers to run or
code if we
write our training application in python
using tensorflow
scikit learn xd boost or pytorch
if you are using pre-built containers
then you can just provide the path to
the training package in
cloud storage you can also build your
own custom containers
if you wish to and in that case you
provide a location to the container
from your container registry or your
artifact registry
if you're not sure whether to use
pre-built or custom containers then
check out the link i've included below
in both cases you would need a folder
within
cloud storage bucket to put your model
output artifacts into when running
custom training jobs on vertex ai
we can also make use of vertex's hyper
parameter
tuning service if you're not familiar
with hyper parameters there are
variables that govern the process
of training your model such as batch
size or
number of hidden layers in a deep neural
network in hyperparameter tuning jobs
the vertex ai
creates trials of your training job with
different sets of hyper parameters
and then searches for the best
combination of hyper parameters
across a series of those trials now to
run the training
you need compute resources it can be
either
single node or multiple worker pools for
distributed training
this is also the step where you would
select the type of machines the cpus the
disk size
and the disk type and the accelerators
such as gpus
and once that training is done we need
the trained model
as an endpoint to be served for
predictions
in vertex ai we can do that by using
pre-built containers
that are supported runtimes such as
tensorflow
scikit-learn pytorch or you can also
build
your own custom container that is stored
in container registry or
artifact registry of course if you just
need the model artifacts to be
downloaded
then you can skip these steps altogether
or you can just use the model for batch
predictions
now that we have the basic understanding
of our custom training choices
let's help fuel symbol train and serve a
custom model
that predicts the fuel efficiency of a
vehicle
we will be using tensorflow to build
this model and then we'll package our
training code in a docker container so
let's see
in the google cloud console before we
begin make sure to enable the vertex ai
api
compute engine and container registry
apis
in this example we will use notebooks to
create the code for our docker container
but you can use any environment you like
to do this
create a new notebook instance with the
latest version
of tensorflow enterprise for this
particular demo i am training without
gpus but depending on your use case
choose gpus if you need them now that
our instance is created
let's open the jupyter lab and navigate
to the terminal
window in our notebook for the purpose
of this demo we will
use the training code that already
exists in tensorflow docs to predict
the fuel efficiency of a vehicle it uses
the
auto mpg data set from kaggle to predict
and i've included the link below to this
page
what we will do here is we submit the
training job to vertex ai
by putting our training code in a docker
container and
pushing the container to google
container registry
using this approach we can train a model
built
with any framework now our first step
is to create a docker file this docker
file uses
one of the deep learning container
tensorflow enterprise
docker images now the deep learning
containers on google cloud
come with many common machine learning
and data science frameworks
pre-installed
the one we're using here includes
tensorflow enterprise pandas
scikit-learn and others now after
downloading that image
this docker file sets up the entry point
for our training code and
we haven't created these files yet but
we will do that
now before that we need a cloud storage
bucket to export our trained tensorflow
model
into vertex ai will then use this bucket
to read our imported model assets
and to deploy the model now for our
model code
let's create a trainer directory and a
train dot py
file we would add our training code to
the train dot py
file here i have adapted the code from
the tensorflow docs for
the model to predict fuel efficiency for
the vehicles
now if you're interested in using the
same code follow the code lab that's
linked below
we need to make sure we update the
bucket variable with the name of the
storage bucket that we just created
earlier
now we need to build and test the
container locally
let's run the container within our
notebook to see if it is working
correctly
now it's building now
and now that it is built let's run this
container
there it is working fine
in a production environment training
will likely take longer which is why
you would want to run it on the cloud
now let's see how to do that
now we push it to google container
registry so vertex ai can
access it with our container pushed to
container registry
we are now ready to kick off a custom
model training job
now we go to the training in vertex ai
and select
no managed data sets since our data set
is being pulled from the source in our
model code
now vertex ai gives us two options for
training the models
with auto ml we can train high quality
models with minimal effort and machine
learning expertise
and we covered this in our previous
episodes so check them out
now here we are using custom training
give the model a name and in container
settings
we have two options now pre-built
containers support
pytorch cycle learn tensorflow and xg
boost
it requires us to package and upload our
application code and dependencies to a
cloud storage bucket
now because we have our own custom
container on
google container registry we will select
custom container here
which supports not just the common
machine learning frameworks but also
non-machine learning dependencies
libraries and binaries
now we provide our image url and our
cloud storage
bucket and we will see hyper parameter
tuning in later episodes so let's leave
this unchecked for now and continue
in compute and pricing we set up a
standard machine
since this model trains quickly but
you're welcome to experiment with
larger machine types and gpus if you
like just remember that if you use the
gpus
you will need to use a gpu-enabled base
container image
the prediction container section is
where we specify
how we would like to serve our model now
here we use pre-built containers
and we provide the path to our cloud
storage bucket
and we're ready for training
we can check to see the training in
progress this could take some time i
have fast forwarded the process here
for you now that our model is trained we
need to deploy it to
an endpoint to make predictions now give
it a name and since this is a demo
we will just leave the traffic split at
100
and enter one for minimum number of
compute
nodes depending on the use case you can
set the maximum number of nodes for auto
scaling when the traffic on the endpoint
is
high i'm selecting a standard machine
type here
pick the one that makes sense for your
use case and deploy
deploying the endpoint will take a few
minutes
and when it is done we can see it in
our endpoint tab now that our endpoint
is deployed we can start making
predictions
we will get predictions on our trained
model from a python
notebook using the vertex ai python sdk
but you can get predictions from any
environment you'd like
so i'm back in our notebook instance and
creating a python 3 notebook from the
launcher
now we install the vertex ai sdk
then add a cell to import the sdk
and create a reference to the endpoint
we just deployed
replace the endpoint and the project id
with
our values of the endpoint and project
id
and then finally we make a prediction to
our endpoint
with some test data and there's our
predicted value
with that we've helped our friends at
fuel symbol train a custom model using
vertex ai
we provided the training code in custom
container and used tensorflow model here
but you can train a model built with any
framework
using custom containers then we deployed
the tensorflow model
using pre-built containers and we
finally created a model
endpoint and generated a prediction in
the next video
we will build vision model using automl
in the meantime let's continue our
discussion in the comments below
and don't forget to like and subscribe
you